[Applause]
this I blame you for all of this this is
oh my goodness oh you're kidding me
you're kidding me
welcome to pod Champs ladies and
gentlemen our first matchup of the day
is Frank and Jarvis so let's just dive a
little bit deeper into Frank uh and well
and Jarvis I mean for lack of a better
word Frank the he you know what's
interesting he's a chess YouTube
sensation he's a tick tock sensation
first one day I was scrolling and I just
hear oh that's a cheeky move and I'm
like who is this dude it's so funny he
pre-moved the whole game that was his
original Tick Tock he's now got over 60
million views he plays on uh mostly he
streams mostly on YouTube plays on
chess.com all the time he's played over
a thousand games got up to 800 and he
hit a brick wall recently he got to 902
now he's down to around 800 and uh I
think we actually have a live view of
him he's right now praying I I hope they
hear the word cheeky today uh Jarvis
mentioned to me briefly he's played some
chess as a teenager I think up to like a
certain age and then stopped YouTuber
twitch streamer does a lot of different
content he's been nominated for the
streaming uh the streamy awards multiple
times he does I like his content a lot
very easy stuff to throw up on the
screen 10-15 minutes boom you laugh you
have a good time you know him well too
right yeah Jarvis is a man who can wear
many hats I have to say recently
obviously he fought and Creator clash
with me but he also has a huge podcast
on YouTube called the sad boys podcast
we interview some of the biggest
YouTubers in the world so whether he's
training for boxing he doesn't interview
me yeah maybe he'll take us on one day
you know maybe before we make a good
impression today but he is playing your
Prodigy student so if anything he'll
take me on and not you because you
should be rooting against him ah there
we go all right here's the game here's
here's your beautiful fried liver
almost yeah he it he didn't play Knight
F3 but this is The Bishop's opening oh
great move by Jarvis by the way this
this removes all four move Checkmate
stuff
and uh now we're in a regular King spawn
I think that's a good sign as long as
Frank's not getting mated in the first
10 moves this is this is a very good
sign
yeah he's targeting the pawn in the
center let's see if Jarvis just goes for
like a typical okay wow the pawn has
been grabbed
look at that
okay we have some tricky lines let's see
how well oh Frank has a juicy 850 rating
he was 200 last time I saw him play
Blitz of course rapid is different so
you know he technically looks like the
favorite right now but we don't know
what is Frank doing
he just looked over and he was just
wide-eyed rubbing his hands together
screaming does he know it's his move
he's manifesting and it's all about the
energy that you bring to the game he's
playing the Mind Games
I'm this is good this is what I learned
from boxing as well not about what you
fight it's just how intimidating you can
be mentally
okay now I see why he's
mixing his hands together
if I okay do I just go there
okay boom I go do I go there oh I think
he's gonna try to set up Jarvis I'm
gonna try to meet him early in the game
okay blue Michael's there getting really
excited over this position
he takes there
okay we're gonna go there and give a
check
um he's very excited about this check
it's not gonna do much but
I'm glad he's okay I called that by the
way
um if I do I go there he takes away but
what if Knight F7 is winning the game
do I do that
um I feel it so I do go there okay he
doesn't stop I can't even come here no
don't do that what are you doing
yeah
why didn't this ladies and gentlemen is
Gotham chess's Prodigy student Frank who
he actually coach it's because he's been
hanging out with you okay next he's
gonna hang his wait what just happened
oh oh but Jarvis Jarvis doesn't work out
oh my God wait this is actually gonna
work out for Frank yes yes Frank's big
idea why can't I go backwards what is
going on Bring It Back chess.com how do
I how do I go back the show of spring
show us Frank I want to see if he's
gonna see it Queen here he just had to
go backwards he just had to relax oh he
didn't play but he did no Frank traded
the queen
no
no Frank
you know he took a risk and it was a bad
move but it could have paid off but now
that even that it's now it's just oh but
but now he has it again Bishop takes
Pawn Jarvis had to go backwards oh and
he's on the board
sounds like a cheeky sack worked off now
you should be extremely proud you could
say this was all calculated all part of
the Mind Game I I it was it was not
calculated and that's kind of the my my
like my concern with Frank as his coach
is if you leave Frank in a room for two
minutes the room will be on fire
everything in the room will be destroyed
like for no reason he gets super excited
on the fifth move of the game and I'm
like Frank it's move five you know and
he screams and screams and then he gives
away a night
um but honestly Frank is kind of my
favorite now I like I like the energy he
brings I don't care if it's not good
chess
that's true now we could say this is
open I think Frank is going to take the
pawn though which is technically the
best yes technically it's the best even
if he falls for the bait yeah this could
be some GM level play right here
but actually I think for beginners Andre
I don't know you could disagree with me
yeah taking this is what I would prefer
because you go there your Bishop is
going to get trapped and he actually
does take the Knight
I think he would have taken the pawn and
then eventually realized the Knight was
still hanging and just kind of walked
into the best move but so far Frank's
Wild Card energy versus Jarvis's mature
well-experienced chess is working very
well yeah Jarvis is playing like a like
a full-on professional uh just calmly
sitting there head in his head
um yeah that's like that's chess player
pose wondering why you showed up to play
in the first place and have Frank
other hand and he just
does not even think he just
Asian it's not a bad move because he is
winning so trading a bishop for a night
is not bad but you really don't want to
trade the bishop because look how easily
black can create an attack this is the
problem this is he should have kept his
Bishop this is
I am worried for for a low rated all
black needs to do is develop and it's
gonna be not very easy for Frank to
defend I could see Frank bringing out a
bishop and covering the back rank like
will Jarvis realize that he doesn't have
to take the pawn and he has to move the
bishop this is the best move if he plays
Bishop H3 I I I'm he's going to win the
tournament yeah like I'm sorry this is
fully zoned in he hasn't moved he has a
stoic pose and he moves the bishop
okay not the move I said so he's still a
a you know very good player but I said
if he finds this move to snuggle the
king and oh that would have been game
over
um now Rook D5 hitting the Knight with
the bishop and The Rook comes down
that's why chess.com gave this a
question mark Rude by the way and that
move is winning on the spot these two
moves are now winning for black because
of the threat on the night and the
attack on the back rank wow
he is a killer
well oh my goodness
you don't think a move like what Bishop
E3 we survive
well actually I think it's even better
to save the Knight and just go for a run
this is why the bishop on H3 would have
been lethal because the king can't come
up you have to try to suffocate a king
that's trying to escape off of the back
rank I'm not sure Frank is going to see
that he might also
he did see it okay I think
uh counter attack keeping up the
pressure this is even better
wow that's an incredible move but
now Rook F5
hits the bishop and you can't take
because of the pin that's the winning
move Rook F5 setting up an attack while
this Knight is hanging I don't know if
he sees that that's ridiculous that is
if Jarvis sees the pin piece because
otherwise it looks like maybe he's
losing the pawn on ec7 if you don't
realize that you're gonna be threatening
that Bishop in one move it looks like
maybe white could come back a little bit
yeah if he doesn't see that and he's
only got any any and he hangs The Rook
completely he's blundered the roof Come
Back Time Frank the Tank Frank the Tank
this is good I this is what I wanted
this is what I wanted yeah and Frank is
down 20 seconds Frank is 50 50 seconds
on the clock he plays A4 because he
doesn't know what else to do if Jarvis
just stays composed and he's taking the
pawns oh my goodness and he could just
go win these pawns next 98 Check Yes I
knew that Frank was going to do that but
oh no the knights
maybe not completely winning but I mean
this actually could be a winning end
game and he snatches that he's winning
Frank is up three pawns but does he know
how to win this or is he just going to
push oh my goodness if he doesn't get
his King off the back rank oh King G4
King oh my goodness there's a mate if
Frank doesn't bring his King up he might
get checkmated King G4 is a fork though
pushing it sometimes he's panicking
the king is coming
okay oh Jarvis has to go right here to
prevent the king from escaping and then
Checkmate but that's the only way he can
might get baited by the check though
rookie seven game over it's a rook trade
it's a rook trade for Frank wow
wow
and just push the F Pawn
that that's there's a pawn there Frank
you can't
hey he's clicking them one by one and
eventually he'll realize the f-pawn yes
okay Pace them all okay but he's getting
in over there and Jarvis had to go to E5
there he had to get in the Square if
you're watching this as a chess beginner
learn what the square is it was still
losing but now Frank is getting a queen
Andrea the only thing remaining will
there be a stalemate I don't know Frank
is known for his viral clippable moments
so I really based on his play so far
don't know but he has played a beautiful
tricky game Andrea there's a stalemate
coming Pawn here take King G4 he pushes
and it's a stalemate oh my goodness well
you clearly you I'm sure you taught
Frank about stalemate no okay
[Applause]
this I blame you for all of this this is
oh my goodness
Andrea you just do the con oh God
welcome to pod Champs ladies and
gentlemen
this is re this is real right this I
don't know if you're setting me up or
something I genuinely can't tell I think
this is real
I'm I'm that's I am Wild
um all I have to say is if I was Frank's
coach we would have had a mate
let's go see Frank's reaction
[Music]
okay this is real it wasn't afraid oh
you're kidding me you're kidding me
no I didn't see the stalemate
I didn't see it
oh you're absolutely sounds like a
broken man oh you're taking the neck
you're taking the milk okay all right
well after our very first game welcome
to pog Champs by the way if you're not
watching that is how we start off POG
champs this is what POG Champs is about
making your chess teachers suffer Jarvis
plays E4 and Frank's been playing the
French is this you did you did you uh
teach me first of all it's my sister
plays the French not me I would never
teach the French
um but I also taught him nothing because
I I don't think he was very interested
in lessons he just wanted to wing it and
do his thing which he's he's sure doing
he might even blunder his Rook if he's
not yeah that's a very scary sniper
so
yeah I mean and that's what he did oh
goodness he took so quick
he didn't even think about it he didn't
even reflect
Jarvis is so good
oh my goodness
I wonder when Jarvis will say his first
word
I bet you he's just gonna log off we're
not even gonna get to interview him if
he wins oh my goodness he is sensitive
Jarvis is insane he's playing very well
and I mean yeah from what I've seen from
Jarvis the amount of projects he can
handle I know when he does something he
does it full-fledgingly and his chest is
great and that's exactly what I expected
but Frank the wild card once again you
know last game he had a Checkmate turn
into a stalemate maybe this game the
loss will turn into a win typically I'm
always telling my students don't go for
these Queen moves not in the beginning
but this is just this is game over and
Jarvis hasn't been missing so I won't be
surprised if he finds this check yeah
you never want to play Queen H5 against
the fully equipped Army because the
queen on her own like will just get
booted but this is so this is really bad
this is like the loan shark coming to
collect you've got absolutely nothing
here he doesn't see it that happens he's
still completely winning the principles
yep and he's very principled player
yeah like one left on his own he does
not burn the house down Frank does and
also his neighbor's house like that's
the difference I I formulate to Frank
with that
yeah I mean I mean three is just easy
now we see the advantage of having the
bishop here you can Castle
um
it means there's a chance for Frank the
Queen's not coming in the king is
safe for a little bit longer this is
making me optimistic
Queen E7 is a nice move from Frank by
the way uh he can trap the bishop by
going there after he moves the Knight so
Jarvis can't fall asleep at the wheel
here he's gotta he's gotta cause some
problems or he's gonna lose the bishop
and then Frank is actually back in the
game uh what do you think Andrea just
Bishop E2 and Castle or
yeah I mean Jarvis seems so principled
like nothing he's he's up material he's
gonna develop he's gonna castle and I
have a feeling he's just gonna slowly
squeeze the win he doesn't really care
about that Bishop he doesn't need it
at the same time I think he's creative
enough to find a way out I don't know
how I don't know how he's gonna do it
but I kind of trust him I like to
because at the very least you want to
give away the bishop for the pawn so
when your Bishop gets strapped right you
don't lose it for nothing it's called
the Desperado
you lose the bishop for the pawn because
you were going to lose it for free
Jarvis had to attack the king while it
was still in the center but Frank has
castled and
Jarvis has lost his Advantage because
he's opening the center of the board
he's up a little bit of material
or maybe it's like equal now that his
his pawns have lost uh he's lost a
couple pawns yeah finally the
long-awaited Jarvis tune in yes let's
tune in on Jarvis Let's Hear His
Thoughts
ah yes
good one
stop everybody be quiet
profound stuff profound stuff from
Professor I think he's gonna win it all
or else Frank will go here
and here and apparently now oh rookie
rookie
Jarvis has great instincts and a great
thought process I think he just needs
like one chess lesson to learn the
basics and learn about castling and then
he could really win this whole thing
yeah seriously she learns about castling
though
Frank is winning the king now has to
start moving if you block with the
bishop the Knight comes in
and it's bad news
okay this would actually be insane he
has to make a block he has to make a
block
or do I want to go there
then
um okay we'll go okay boom we'll go
there next
hokey dokey will go boom there next all
right all right yeah we're gonna go
there we're gonna defend that pawn some
more that takes her I'll just take there
uh nothing threatening my queen right
now or composure Frank composure is my
best friend
okay we're currently winning a trade-off
right here okay boom I go there he takes
and I take then he takes then I'll take
I okay having said all of this amazing
stuff that he just did about the night
move
I don't know if he's looking
that that's the thing he does these
amazing moves he doesn't see the winning
blend but then he stumbles into it so
just like like a little lost toddler
stumbling through the woods that just
somehow keeps surviving but I think like
if he sees this bishop A4 this is game
over
very uncomfortable but he has no choice
yeah and he's only got 40 seconds Jarvis
he's got to make a move oh
is forced to take with the King here
okay
to walk over and still but that's tough
okay there's no more made on C7 now
Frank just has to bring in the Army he
might accidentally open just if it give
King here it's mate by the way
oh Queen C2 is made on the board
what oh God oh God come on Frank take
this one home Frank could also go here
and hang his Queen like it Queen C2
he's cooking he's cooking I think this
is it on the board and he's won it Queen
C2 mate okay Frank delivers the kiss of
death
and I think but after that stalemate I
needed to see him finish
hokey dokey
who's there I'll give a check he moves
there I'll give a check
okay now
I'm gonna go
um now we'll go boom we'll go there okey
dokey we're gonna go oh wait is that me
is that me okay
come on
literally a miniature
that's how I cook
that's how he cooks
come on and the house is on fire
I almost feel bad for Frank because I
mean for Jarvis
he played so well and this shit's so
unfortunate that's how I roll baby he's
still going imagine losing to this guy
and soon again oh my goodness well you
heard it here first ladies and gentlemen
Frank the chess Prodigy is a mixture of
Hans demon and Austin Powers and he gets
the first win of pogchamps five in a
ridiculous back and forth affair with
the mysterious Jarvis Jarvis coming in
with an unclear chess pedigree and it
was very very quality chess there for an
hour uh I am crazy don't sleep on Jarvis
I'm gonna see if he wants like a
principal chess lesson because I think
once he learns about he learns about
castling these next few games aren't
gonna go like this
[Music]
[Applause]
foreign
[Music]